[Música]
voy a pedirles que cierren los ojos
y piense cada uno de ustedes cuál es la
ruta que quiere construir cuál es esa
ruta y algo que les apasiona de algo que
les mueve y algo que con todo su corazón
que quisieran realizar
eso
hoy fernando nos ha comentado que las
nueve de eso que rosario
que hoy vicky nos va a compartir que
marco nos va a compartir que alejandra
nos costó
y quiero además que piensen cierren los
ojos
que eso que esa ruta que quieren
construir
cruza fronteras
cruza madres y se va a otros continentes
crece sorprende
conquista otros mundos
y que esa ruta de cada uno de ustedes
que ahora se lo están imaginando
converge en un camino
y ese camino es donde todos nos
encuentran porque es un camino
qué es el país que es un país grande un
país de talento un país rico un país que
ha sido construido por cada uno de
ustedes
quiero que abran los ojos
estamos ahora en la realidad y quiero
preguntarle si eso es posible
quiero que me respondan si eso es
posible
hoy quiero compartir con ustedes una
historia y esa historia va a permitir
que construyamos a lo largo de estos
minutos esa posibilidad esa posibilidad
que las rutas de cada uno
o sea enormemente rica y que convergen
en un camino en ese camino que estamos
buscando
pero antes quiero que vean y que
recorramos que retrocedamos en el tiempo
y veamos cuáles son los caminos que como
país y las rutas que hemos transitado
como país
han escuchado hablar de la ruta decían
es la ruta de los reyes
la ruta real es la ruta de la plata pero
una de las rutas más importantes en la
época
de la colonia
han escuchado hablar de la ruta del gas
más presente
la ruta de la agricultura
de nuestros productos agrícolas
cuáles son las rutas que hemos elegido a
lo largo de nuestra historia rutas donde
el centro son productos es la planta que
sale de bolivia y se transporta cruza
mares cruza el continente si se va
la ruta
de nuestro gas sale de nuestra tierra
cruza países cruza continentes y se van
la ruta de bolivia es una ruta de salir
de productos de nuestros productos
naturales que salen
la ruta que los invito a construir es
una ruta que rompe ese patrón es la ruta
de la innovación y es una ruta que la
construye somos nosotros son las
personas y donde el cambio las
posibilidades el sueño de crecimiento de
desarrollo de futuro no está en sacar si
no está en conquistar es en conquistar
ese conocimiento ese talento que tenemos
como personas y que es posible
transportarlo a los lugares más lejanos
y de la manera más sorprendente y rica
posible
y esta historia se construye con un
propósito
con ese propósito con el que ustedes
estaban imaginando se hace un momento y
que cada uno de ustedes tiene ese
propósito ha hecho que bolivianos
ya lo estén haciendo y que son un
ejemplo de no solo haber cumplido su
sueño de haber construido su propia ruta
de haber conquistado su propia ruta sino
que eso
ha trascendido ha llegado a otros
continentes ha sido reconocido
y son un referente como bolivianos en el
mundo ese esa es la ruta que quiero
invitarles a construir
es la xunta
que ha construido juan claudio de oliva
maya juan claudio de oliva mayas
boliviano de padre cubano y madre
beniana que hace hasta hace poco está ha
estado en costa rica ahora está en
bolivia y ha construido una solución
para bolivia y para el mundo que ha sido
reconocida
jorge ruiz él vive en miami boliviano
paseño él ha construido una ruta desde
miami y está conquistando el mundo ayer
me escribió en el whatsapp que está en
asia un boliviano con talento dando
soluciones que niega que salen de
bolivia y van al mundo y cambian el
mundo
jeremy marcial con gatti box un
boliviano suizo que construyó un cerebro
inteligente para reducir
significativamente el costo de la
energía y que hoy su solución
inteligente de energía verde ha sido
premiada en francia en jorge ruiz en
miami en juan claudio bolivia maya en
costa rica
mohamed 2 tajo cruceño de padre de padre
de padre keniano que armado una de las
soluciones más maravillosas que conozco
a partir de su pasión la ciencia
trayendo lo mejor de la ciencia del
mundo a bolivia y exportando desde
bolivia una solución para el mundo hoy
en varios países no solamente en
latinoamérica lucían damují a una
solución que ser cover de nuestro
problema ambiental que desde cualquier
parte del mundo alguien ponga un cerco a
la deforestación y guardemos lo que
tenemos cualquier persona desde el mundo
puede hacerlo desde el internet y lograr
que desde bolivia tengamos una zona
opción para el mundo y para nuestro país
carlos jordán con una solución que
hablando este de leonardo sobre el tema
inmobiliario también tiene una solución
que ahora la está trabajando para
exportarla al mundo y tener presencia
carlos salinas el año pasado ha sido
elegido el emprendedor el emprendedor
del año de méxico para seño que ahora su
solución no sólo este méxico como una de
las soluciones entre las 10 que está
logrando que la mayor parte de los
mexicanos millennials quieran trabajar
en su empresa compitiendo con google con
amazon su tecnología su conocimiento
para méxico para el mundo y por qué no
para bolivia puedo seguir
somos son bolivianos que están haciendo
que su pasión sea una pasión que se
vuelva empresa que se vuelva solución
que se vuelva pasión
y ese y esa pasión ha tenido este
recorrido que todos viven en ese ámbito
en esa ilusión de cambiar las cosas el
éxito consiste en ir de fracaso en
fracaso sin perder el entusiasmo que
mueve nuestro entusiasmo nuestra pasión
ese sueño esos minutos en los cuales
ustedes estaban pensando ahora que como
lo hacemos que ser que receta y cómo lo
logramos como lo han hecho ellos como
carol acá pero también con una con una
solución lo está haciendo que nos mueve
y ahí tenemos algunas frases que son
profundas y que nos guían las
oportunidades se encuentran en el lugar
donde están las quejas queridos míos
salgan a la esquina hay miles de cosas o
necesidades que resolver cada uno de
ustedes tiene una que resolver que le
puede apasiona
cuando el éxito no es para los que creen
que lo pueden hacer sino para los que
hacen hoy hoy levántense salgan de esta
de este evento y digan cuál es esa
pasión como la pasión de fernando de
defender a la a los animales y que
ninguno está en las calles como la
pasión de alejandra de romper barreras y
cambiar el que uno tiene para empezar a
hacer como ese chip que ustedes tienen
hoy están en la posibilidad de cambiarlo
como la gran clave fue crear un producto
pensando en el cliente y los problemas
que tiene el cliente david vélez 15
millones de usuarios colombianos que
este en brasil y méxico- unicornio que
lo mueve el amor porque la gente no
sufra buscando un crédito pensando que
quiero hacer su vida fácil y feliz eso
me mueve quiero dar de corazón una
solución
esa es la pasión que tengo su pasión lo
ha llevado a resolver la vida en
latinoamérica de millones de personas en
corto plazo que usando la tecnología
como todos los demás que lo han hecho la
tecnología está en nuestras manos usemos
la
prime el mundo no las está ofreciendo
para que lo hacemos con quien con
personas entre nosotros con talentos
contándonos no no solos con esfuerzo
viendo que qué solución nos puede unir a
un grupo a las instituciones oa más
porque las cosas no se hacen siguiendo
caminos distintos para que no sean
iguales sino para que sean mejores
queremos mejorar tenemos un compromiso
son los países somos personas con ese
compromiso somos bolivianos que si nos
mueve algo es ese la pasión por nuestro
país
la pasión por hacer algo la pasión por
cambiar para qué
para ese camino cada uno de nosotros
viendo un problema una queja viendo que
hay algo que resolver tomando no los en
la mano para resolverlo creando es
innovación haciendo uso de lo que el
mundo nos ofrece como lo han hecho
bolivianos y con resultados
sorprendentes
esa es la transformación y el camino que
queremos construir porque el camino no
está en gobiernos que dan solución hoy
el camino está en nuestras manos porque
cada persona hace cambios y por qué lo
mueve no lo mueve el poder no lo mueve
los intereses lo mueve la pasión y
cuando mueve la pasión una persona en
conjunto con otras cambia construye y
transforma los invito a que ser parte de
esa transformación
cuál es esa transformación que estamos
haciendo el círculo azul todas las
personas que están logrando romper
paradigmas y
crear la ruta una ruta que ya no sea esa
ruta que estamos acostumbrados somos
parte de eso y están invitados a hacerlo
soy claro la cámara tengo una solución
también que se llama credit creo que
está haciendo con presencia en 12 países
es hacer la posibilidad que cada persona
no te pueda ver tenga la posibilidad de
acceder a un crédito de aprender
educación financiera y ser gerente de su
propia iniciativa les agradezco mucho
por estar